[Musique]
une commission permanente exceptionnel
s'est tenu ce 27 mars dans l'hémicycle
du palais de la source
une procédure d'urgence suite à la
propagation du virus kovy 19 qui plonge
la réunion dans un état d'urgence
sanitaire social et économique afin de
répondre à cette situation le
département a élaboré un pacte de
solidarité d'urgence sociale afin
d'accompagner les publics prioritaires
de la collectivité
nous avons voté une enveloppe de 41,5
millions d'euros pour venir en aide à
nos publics les plus fragiles
je pense aux gramounes je pense aussi
aux personnes en situation de handicap
je pense à l'enfance vulnérable et sans
oublier les travailleurs tous ceux qui
travaillent au domicile des personnes
âgées dans les structures comme de gré à
gré je pense aussi aux assistantes
familiales aux assistantes maternelles
tools et public là sont concernés par le
dispositif on a voté et permettez moi de
souligner aussi le rôle essentiel des
centres communaux d'action sociale les
ccs qui font un travail remarquable
le département a décidé de voter une
aide de cinq millions d'euros en
direction des crs c'est 5 millions
d'euros vont leur permettre de mettre en
place tout un circuit de solidarité au
profit des publics les plus fragiles les
plus vulnérables parmi les priorités
visé le soutien aux personnes âgées avec
une faible retraite il faut pouvoir
s'équiper dans des produits de
protection sanitaire de l'hydrogène
ensuite de tout ce qui touche à voilà au
masque qui vont arriver
moi je veux permettre aux familles qui
touchent des petites retraites à nos
gramounes qui touchent des petites
retraites de pouvoir s'équiper et le
département débloque une aide
exceptionnelle durant cette crise 250
euros par personne touchant moins de 500
euros de retraite
c'est un acte de solidarité c'est un
acte de générosité pour les familles les
enfants confiés à la zone l'aide sociale
à l'enfance le département souhaite
apporter des moyens complémentaires aux
assistants familiaux qui accueille 80 %
des enfants placés les enfants qui sont
placés dans des familles d'accueil ne
doit pas être oubliée en cette période
difficile il n'y a pas de cours ils sont
confinés à domicile c'est une chaîne aux
familles d'accueil donc le département a
décidé d'augmenter l'enveloppé dédiée à
cela d'abord pour les frais d'entretien
journalier de 15 à 30 euros par enfant
voilà ce que nous avons voté
deuxièmement voient leur permettre de
s'épanouir malgré le confinement est
bien possibilité d'acheter des jeux
éducatifs mais aussi pour continuer leur
scolarité
si cela était nécessaire pouvoir chez
des tablettes numériques pour leur
permettre de toujours suivre les cours
malgré le confinement à domicile
plus de deux millions d'euros ont été
consacrés à la commande de masques et de
gênes
l'ensemble de ces dispositifs prendra
effet dès la semaine prochaine
[Musique]